♪ ♪
>> Judge Jeanine:
PRESIDENT BIDEN DESPERATELY
WANTS YOU TO THINK HIS
SPUTTERING ECONOMY IS DOING
WELL, ROLLING OUT A PLAN TO
SPEND SKY HIGH INFLATION AND GAS
PRICES AND KEEP SETTING NEW
RECORDS.
HOLDING A RARE OVAL OFFICE
LEAVING THIS AFTERNOON WITH
JEROME POWELL.
AND JOE BIDEN SHARING HIS PLANS
TO FIGHT INFLATION IN
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" OP-ED.
THE GOAL APPEARS TO BE TO
COMMENCE UPSET VOTERS SO THAT
THINGS AREN'T THAT BAD AND TRY
TO PASS THE INFLATION BLAME ONTO
REPUBLICANS.
THE PRESIDENT CLAIMS TO KNOW
WHAT HE IS DOING, BUT ONE OF HIS
TOP ADVISORS IS REFUSING TO
ANSWER SIMPLE QUESTIONS.
>> SO GIVE US A FORECAST, WHERE
CAN YOU HAVE GAS PRICES, LET'S
SAY BY THE END OF THE YEAR.
WHERE WILL THEY BE?
>> THIS IS A SERIOUS ISSUE, AND
WHAT YOU ARE DOING RIGHT NOW IS
TRYING TO PUT ME IN THE DECISION
OF BEING A FORECASTER.
>> WHAT IS YOUR ABILITY TO
CONTROL THOSE PRICES AND BRING
THEM DOWN?
>> WHAT YOU WANT FROM YOUR
PRESIDENT IS THAT THEY ARE DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN.
>> Judge Jeanine: CURIOUS,
SANDRA, I WATCH THAT BACK AND
FORTH.
HE REFUSED TO GIVE YOU AN ANSWER
AND COULD NOT GIVE YOU AN
ANSWER.
WHAT WAS YOUR TAKE ON IT?
>> Sandra: I FELT THAT THEY
WERE REALLY FAIR QUESTIONS AND
NOT SIMPLE SOLUTIONS, BUT HE DID
NOT OFFER SPECIFIC ANSWERS OF
WHAT THEY ARE DOING TO BRING THE
PRICES DOWN.
I HAD VERY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHY THEY ARE TOUTING THIS
ECONOMY IN SOME POSITION OF
STRENGTH WHILE PEOPLE ARE PAYING
HIGH GAS PRICES THE NEW RECORD
HIGH AND INFLATION IS AT A 40
YEAR HIGH IN THIS COUNTRY AND
ALSO ASKED HIM IF IT IS
REACTING.
BUT HE TRYING TO GET AHEAD OF
THINGS GETTING EVEN WORSE HERE?
YOU HAVE HAD LARRY SUMMERS,
STEVE RATNER, INSIDE DEMOCRATIC
ADMINISTRATIONS WHO HAVE BEEN
WAVING THE FLAG, THE RED FLAG ON
WHAT HAS HAPPENED WITH THE
ECONOMY FOR QUITE SOME TIME AND
THERE IS NOWHERE TO RUN AND HIDE
NOW.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" LITERALLY
JUST PUBLISH THIS PIECE ON THE
MISJUDGMENT OF THE WHITE HOUSE
OF THE INFLATION THREAT UNTIL IT
WAS TOO LATE AND IT GOES DATE BY
DATE WHICH THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WAS PLAYING DOWN
THE ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES OF THE
POLICIES.
GOING BACK TO JULY 19, YOU
REMEMBER THE INFLATION BEING
TRANSITORY AND THEN IT WAS
SHIFTING THE BLAME TO THE
COMPANIES, RIGHTS?
THAT IT WAS SHIFTING THE
VLADIMIR PUTIN INVADING UKRAINE,
SO I WAS JUST TRYING TO HOLD THE
WHITE HOUSE ACCOUNTABLE AS WE
GIVE THEM A LOT OF TIME TO
EXPLAIN THEIR PLAN AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE DIDN'T REALLY
GET IT.
>> Judge Jeanine: ALL RIGHT,
JESSE, SANDRA SAID, WELL, YOU
SAID INFLATION WAS TRANSITORY,
WHY CAN'T YOU GIVE US AN IDEA?
THEY EVEN MET TODAY WITH
JEROME POWELL, AND THEY KEEP
INSISTING THAT IT IS NOT WHAT
THEY THINK IT IS.
>> Jesse: THE ECONOMY IS
GREAT, WAKE UP, SIR, 75% OF THE
COUNTRY SAYS THAT IT IS AN
ABSOLUTE YOU KNOW WHAT HOLE, AND
TELLING THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
STRUGGLING, YOU DON'T KNOW HOW
GOOD THEY HAVE IT.
WHAT HOUSE HAS HE BEEN WORKING
ON?
AND THEN THE BAD THINGS, NONE OF
IT IS MY FAULT.
IT IS THE FED CHAIR'S FAULT, AND
JUST REAPPOINTED THE FED CHAIR
AND SAYS IT'S CONGRESS' FAULT
TOO, BUT THE DEMOCRATS CONTROL
CONGRESS, THEN SAYS IT IS
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S FAULT, BUT WAS
INVADED ON THE WATCH.
AND IT'S THE SOLUTION, SPEND
MORE MONEY, ANY IDIOT KNOWS THAT
IT'S REALLY DUMB IDEA.
AMERICANS ARE UPSET IN THE
WHITE HOUSE THEY ARE VERY ANGRY
AND A LOT OF THE BLACK VOTERS
SAY WHAT HAVE YOU DONE FOR ME
LATELY?
WE PUT YOU IN THERE AND YOU HAVE
NOT DELIVERED.
SOME OF THE FAR LEFT OF THAT PUT
THEM IN THERE AND HAS NOT
DELIVERED ON THE GREEN NEW DEAL
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT AND ALL
THE DONORS ARE ANGRY TOO.
AND I SAW POLLS AT 35 PERCENT IN
DELAWARE.
HIS HOME STATE HATES HIM.
AT 29 PERCENT IN OHIO WITH A
SENATE RACE IN OHIO IN HIS 30s
IN NEVADA AND GEORGIA AND
ARIZONA.
HOW IS HE GOING TO WIN SENATE
RACE WHEN HE IS DOING THAT BAD.
AND THE ULTRA MEGA BACKFIRED
PRINTING UP T-SHIRTS AND THE
ECONOMY IS TEETERING ON A
RECESSION, NO GOOD FOR SMOKING
JOE.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT DO YOU
THINK THE PLAN IS?
SOME BRIGHT PEOPLE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, THERE HAS TO BE A
PLAN?
WHERE THERE IS PLAN NO LONGER
TRANSITORY, WE WILL FIX THIS,
TELL ME HOW GREAT THINGS ARE.
>> NOEL.
I DON'T WANT TO DO THAT, BUT I
WANT TO TRY TO EXPLAIN WHAT IS
GOING ON HERE.
NO ONE GOES INTO AN ELECTION
SAYING OUR CAMPAIGN STRATEGY IS
SAY EVERYTHING IS.
THAT'S A BAD IDEA.
NO REPUBLICAN OR NO DEMOCRAT
WOULD DO THAT.
AND THERE HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF
FOCUS GROUPS THAT CAME OUT
BETWEEN THE PENNSYLVANIA
ELECTION WITH THE ELECTED
CANDIDATE SAYING DEMOCRATS WON A
FIGHTER.
AND WE OVERWHELMINGLY BELIEVE
THAT REPUBLICANS ARE ALWAYS
READY TO GO TO THE MAT AND THAT
WE SEE TOO MUCH GROUND.
AND I THINK WHAT JOE BIDEN IS
TRYING TO DO IS TO GO A BIT ON
THE OFFENSIVE AND TO ALSO
HIGHLIGHT WHICH A BUNCH OF THE
SURROGATES HAVE BEEN DOING THE
FACT THAT REPUBLICANS EXCEPT FOR
RICK SCOTT'S PLAN WHICH THEY ARE
RUNNING AWAY FROM AREN'T REALLY
OFFERING US MUCH OF AN
ALTERNATIVE.
AND COUPLING THAT WITH BIG
SOCIAL ISSUES GOING ON RIGHT NOW
LIKE GUNS AND POLICE FOCUS
OPINIONS THAT THERE ARE
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS AND
INDEPENDENT VOTERS AND EVEN SOME
MODERATE TO REPUBLICAN VOTERS
THAT CAN BE ANIMATED BY THESE
ISSUES WERE FRANKLY REPUBLICANS
ARE COMPLETELY OUT OF STEP WITH
THE AMERICANS LIKE ICE.
>> Sandra: DOES THE
WHITE HOUSE PLAN TO BRING DOWN
GAS PRICES?
>> Jessica: I THINK HE HAS A
GAS PLAN THAT HE DID OFFER US
MORE DRILLING.
>> Jesse: RELEASING FROM THE
PETROLEUM RESERVE AND THE GAS
PRICES WENT UP.
THAT WAS A PLAN.
>> Judge Jeanine: HE SAID THAT
THEY COULD DO MORE DRILLING AND
THEN HE PULLED BACK ON IT.
>> Jessica: I DON'T THINK THAT
THAT IS RIGHT.
>> Jesse: WENT BACK TO
INCREASE PRODUCTION AND THEY
SAID SCREW YOU.
>> Jessica: EVERYTHING IS,
EVERYTHING ABOUT REPUBLICAN!
>> Jesse: FINALLY.
>> Judge Jeanine: IS AN
IMPORTANT THAT A PRESIDENT FEELS
THE PAIN OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE?
JESSICA SAYING HE CAN'T SAY
EVERYTHING IS CRAPPY.
AT LEAST HE CAN FEEL THE PAIN.
>> Greg: HE WOULD BE A
MASOCHIST BECAUSE HE IS CREATING
THE PAIN, HE SAYS HE WANTS TO
SPEAK FOR HIMSELF, BUT THAT
SEEMS LIKE THAT HAS BEEN THE
PROBLEM SINCE THE BEGINNING.
HE CREATES A WORD SALAD THAT
WOULD GIVE YOU ECO-BUNT E. COLI.
PEOPLE ARE ANIMATED BY ISSUES
LIKE ABORTION AND GUNS, BUT
EVERYONE IS ANIMATED BY
INFLATION.
BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE
THAT ABORTION WILL NEVER ENTER
THEIR LIVES, RIGHT?
BUT INFLATION HITS THEM WHEREVER
THEY ARE.
AND I THINK THAT THAT IS THE
ISSUE.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A SOLUTION FOR
THAT -- I AM LOOKING AT I
BELIEVE THAT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
GIVEN UP.
THEY ARE BEHIND FIVE TOUCHDOWNS
AND THEY ARE CHOOSING TO RUN OUT
THE CLOCK.
BECAUSE CLEARLY THERE IS NO
POLITICAL ROAD BACK FOR JOE.
SO RATHER THAN EVEN HELP A
LITTLE THEY ARE JUST LEAVING THE
FIELD.
>> Jesse: A SPORTS ANALOGY?
>> Greg: I'M NOT EVEN SURE
THAT IT MADE SENSE TO ME.
BECAUSE FRANKLY IT WAS A LONG
WEEKEND AND I AM WORKING ON 10%
OF MY BRAIN.
I COME UP WITH THE ANALOGIES, I
DON'T ASK FOR PERMISSION.
>> Judge Jeanine: ARE YOU
DONE?
>> Greg: NOT REALLY.
IT'S BEEN O